hello and welcome to microsoft research
webinar
i am junon park the pm for microsoft
vision and with sigma lennox
i will be sharing with you the
state-of-the-art computer vision model
that we created here at microsoft
together we will discuss the
implications of our large pre-trained
vision model
how we achieve the state-of-the-art
performance and how you can benefit from
the model that we are making publicly
available
without pre-trained vision models a team
that needs to perform a computer vision
task
would need to first collect a large sum
of labeled data
then spend weeks training either a
convolutional neural network or
transform a model from ground up
for example if a team needs to identify
what landmark is in the image
the team would collect a set of landmark
images label what landmark is in each
image
then wait weeks waiting for a model that
is specialized in doing this one task
to finish training then if the team
needs to
perform another computer vision task
take for example
detect where an animal is in the image
then the team would need to collect
another set of data
animal images and then label of where
animals are in each image
then wait weeks again training yet
another model that can only perform this
one
specific task this means that as the
team grows and the number of tasks
increase
the total cost multiplies the cost grows
linearly with the number of tasks
this also means that if your team
invested into getting
training data to teach a model about one
aspect of the visual world
for example animals it is not being used
to help any other models that may
benefit from understanding about animals
for example a landmark model that can
identify a zoo
because there are animals in the image
general pre-trained vision models on the
other hand seek to build
a general understanding of the visual
worlds of
how images can be projected into the
vector space such that their visual
meaning is preserved
instead of learning from a task-specific
data set for example just animal images
a general pre-trained visual model would
learn from an
unbounded domain such as animals
products
buildings chairs books and drawings
the objective of building a general
model is not to apply the model for one
task
but to build a model that learns
anything and everything that can be
encoded in images
then apply it to any number of vision
tasks
now when we say that a general
pre-trained visual model learns a
general visual representation of images
what we mean is that the model learns
how to encode
pixels into vectors effectively as an
example
one way to build a general pre-trained
visual model would be to train a
convolutional neural network that learns
to perform the
image classification task on imagenet
dataset
once it is trained to predict a diverse
set of classes ranging from chairs to
animals in the imagenet
you could freeze the model remove the
last fully connected layer which would
be predicting the imageness specific
class scores
then use the resulting network to send
in images and get back embedding vectors
an effective on effective image encoder
can convert images into embedding
vectors
such that the distance between the
vectors would correspond to the
disparity between the underlying images
in the example you see there are four
images that are converted to embedding
vectors by
a hypothetical general visual model in
the vector space
the two images you see on the left of
the space needle in seattle
are geometrically near each other in the
vector space because they are similar
images
then these images of space needle are
closer to a palace in korea
than to a mountain in nature since the
buildings are more similar to each other
than to a mountain once we have trained
a model that has a powerful
representational capability
we can take the model's general
understanding of the visual worlds
and apply it to any computer vision task
if a team has a specific task a specific
set of classes into which they need to
classify
images then they can take the image
encoder
and build a linear classifier on top of
it and get a model that produces good
results
without having to collect a large amount
of data and without having to wait weeks
for a model to be trained
now if the team does have a large amount
of test specific data
they can further improve the performance
by fine-tuning the model
that is they would unfreeze the
pre-trained model either entirely or
partially
then continue the back propagation to
update the parameters in the network
using a large pre-trained vision model
then further fine-tuning it
is often key to achieving
state-of-the-art performance on vision
tasks
through this transfer learning process a
general pre-trained visual model can
benefit
any number of tasks such as the examples
you see on the slide
ranging from image classification object
detection
image retrieval and image generation
here at the microsoft being multimedia
group
we have both the need and the ability to
build a large pre-trained visual model
in order to provide products such as the
text to image image search
text to video video search and search by
image visual search
multimedia group has the need to perform
tens of vision tasks
this ranges from detecting where an
object is in the image
retrieving similar looking images
scoring how aesthetically pleasing on
images
and finding out what landmark is shown
in the image
at the same time microsoft is operating
one of the world's largest
search engines and one of the world's
largest cloud services
this means that we have the
infrastructure capable of storing and
processing
web scale data this combination of the
need to perform tens of vision tasks
and the capability to build world
to to leverage web scale data led us to
plan to build a state-of-the-art
pre-trained vision model
and we think we achieved it i'm excited
to announce to you
on behalf of my team that we are making
the resident 50 version of our model
available to the public
you can get your hands on this model by
going to aka dot ms
slash microsoft vision and you can use
this model to advance your deep learning
research or build your own computer
vision products
we are incredibly happy that we are able
to contribute our work to accelerate
deep learning research
and to support the teams across the
planet
to make sure that teams of any size and
with any infrastructure can benefit from
our work
we trained a version of our model on the
resnet50 architecture
which is used widely in the academia and
in the industry
now it is my pleasure to invite sigmunds
the engineer who is in charge of the
microsoft vision model
to walk you through how you can download
microsoft visual model to build an
example image classifier
he will also showcase the
state-of-the-art performance that we
achieved on five popular computer vision
benchmarks
then explain the engineering techniques
that we used to achieve the results
sigmund off to you hello everyone my
name is iglenik and i work at big
multimedia
my main area of focus is a pre-trained
vision model
and today i wanted to walk you through
an example
how using a microsoft vision we can
we can very quickly and in simple way
train a classification model
that will achieve state-of-the-art
results
and today we're gonna
use only one gpu to under uh
and under 10 minutes we'll be able to to
build a model that
will achieve 90 to over 92 percent
accuracy score on cypher 10
and to do that we'll freeze the
microsoft vision model
and just train a linear classifier on
top of the frozen model
which is following a very popular
technique of the papers like
recent clip or other papers from last
year
so let's start by uh necessary imports
uh this is quite standard i think the
only way that
the only thing that is interesting here
is that
uh we'll be using python as as our
backend
and we'll use logistic regression from
scikit learn
now is the now is the value the
the new element that we're adding is
developed by us
microsoft vision python package and this
is python package that
simplifies your development because in
one line
we can download the model transfer its
way to the resnet 50 architecture
and it's and its
interface is based on torch vision
interface so it should be very familiar
to everyone
yeah so let's define how first we'll
pre-process the images
this is pretty standard pre-processing
method used
by used by all the
all the popular research papers the only
thing different here is that
you might notice that we swapped the
image channels
which means that microsoft vision was
trained on
images using bgr format so we need to
transform the images to bgr format
here
as mentioned we'll be using cypher 10
for today's example i've got it already
downloaded
and we're using cipher 10 that is
available
at pytorch so it's
so we can very quickly and in one line
uh use this
data set but please note that this data
set can be
replaced with any data set of your
choose of your choice
without any changes to the rest of the
of the code so you can plug in any data
set
and achieve very good results using the
same code
this is the line that actually takes
care of the importing the
the pre-trained micro microsoft division
model
we can see that it's very simple we
define
that we want this model to be
pre-trained and
actually the only difference between
this package and the third vision
package
is just swapping name torch to name
microsoft and everything should work out
of the box
to improve the speed at of our
computation and to use the fact
that the features of the microsoft
efficient model
are already high quality we can just set
our model to the evaluation mode
and do not fine-tune the whole model
we'll just
surround the forward propagation through
our model
and only the only thing trained will be
the linear
layer the linear regression on top of
that model so we set it to evaluation
mode
and we copy it to a gpu
so that to increase the speed of
computation and as mentioned
this example is using only one gpu so
this is a setup that anyone could
actually follow because it's not too
expensive
this method will take care of
[Music]
of extracting the features of the data
set we can see that it again
it works with any model and any data set
we're passing the data set to
to this method and by using
python data loader we can also increase
the speed of this computation
by increasing batch size and number of
parallel workers that are fetching the
images
and because we're just using the
expensive
microsoft the expensive computation
in a forward propagation we can actually
use quite large batch size per gpu
which in here i set to 128 so we
copy the images and the labels to the
gpu
we run the feature extraction and we
append
all the features and all the labels
together and we catenate the results
after
copying back to the cpu
yep so once we have that we can
extract the train features and and the
the labels from the train set and the
same from
for the test set uh even using one gpu
for cipher 10
this is taking less than two minutes
and now is the actual model that we're
training
uh we're creating a logistic regression
that is a classifier from scikit-learn
package
and also to follow good research
practices
uh we set the maximum number of
iterations to 1000
and we also set a random state to a
fixed integer
zero in this case for our results
reproducible
so that anyone can can also validate our
scars
we also increase the number of parallel
jobs to
to run this computation to increase the
speed
so we fit this model
to with our training features and to fit
it to the train labels
and we predict what uh what are the test
features
and then we just simply measure the
accuracy of
our uh predictions uh against
uh the labels
and the accuracy that you should all get
out of this
is the 92.64 on cypher
10 and it took us 8 minutes to run that
uh so again this is this is
very quick and can scale also on much
larger data sets
so let's talk about the deep learning
techniques that we use to build this
model
the main idea behind it is to use the
multitask learning
with hard parameter sharing hard
parameter sharing means
that we will share the backbone and
share the embedding of the whole model
but we will use multiple classification
layers on top of this model
in this particular case we assembled
four datasets for training
two of them are publicly available which
is imagenet 22k which is a larger
version and a bit lesser known version
of the popular
image in 1k and a microsoft coco
we also scraped
scraped search engines and created
two web supervised data sets and by this
we mean that we used
search query as label for our images
and images returned by the engines as
as the as a data set
and this this idea is
uh is actually quite
uh quite very very practical for for
everyone
to to use a very interesting setup
because this is quite common problem
that many researchers face
that we want to develop good robust
models
and we have multiple data sets available
there are multiple publicly available
data sets we might have
have a data sets of our own and we have
no good way of combining them
and efficiently training on all of them
in parallel
so our idea was to use this multitask
learning
and heart parameter sharing and we
showed that
by this rather simple setup we can
achieve state-of-the-art results
and this also allows our model to be
to be robust and and to be easily
transferable
between domains so because we want this
model to be
to be used in multiple scenarios
so that you can plug in any of the
classification problem or other problems
that you might want to use this model
for
and this model should perform very well
on that
data sets we evaluated our approach on
multiple data sets from different
domains
including some popular general purpose
data sets like
imagenet or cipher or stl and
some more fine-grained data sets like
cub which is bird detection
flowers recognition and svhn which is
actually
house numbers data sets taken from
street photos
on each of these data sets we have
competitive results
and what i'm trying to say is that
whatever your scenario is microsoft
vision model will be a good starting
point for you
which you can use even as is just to
extract features from your
from your images or to further fine-tune
for even better results
if we average scores on those data sets
we actually outperform any other
publicly available models
uh inside the resin 50 architecture
and with that i wanted to
pass it back to june 1. thank you thank
you segments
i hope you enjoyed our presentation and
that you can leverage our model to
achieve amazing results in computer
vision
if you are passionate about creating
world-class computer vision models
i invite you to visit our courier page
at aka dot ms slash bing multimedia jobs
join us at our team so that you can
leverage our web scale data and our web
scale infrastructure
to fulfill your passion once again you
can get your hands on microsoft vision
model
at aka dot ms slash microsoft vision
finally we thank our management and
leadership
mark bolen ravi yada khun wu
minaj merchants arun sachiti and jordi
riebas
for enabling us and this work
thank you and now we are open to answer
your questions and we are now live
and we will be answering the questions
live we noticed some great questions
that you asked during the event that we
believe a lot of questions a lot of
people watching would be interested in
so we'll begin with these questions
please feel free to keep submitting the
questions in the meantime
the first question is from karimullah
sheikh
who asked about what is the objective
function that microsoft vision model was
learned on
sigma would you describe the objective
function aka the loss function
the batch size learning step size any
other hyper parameter that you can share
sure i can share that i know there are
quite a lot of very similar questions
about the technical details
on our approach and since we didn't
publish a paper at least yet
i know it may be quite uh mysterious so
far
but so about objective uh
as i mentioned in the presentation we
used multiple data sets and all of those
datasets were classification datasets
so for all those uh for so the objective
functions were cross-entropy
for all those data sets but it was for
each data set uh it was optimized
separately
after other technical details uh what
was important that we used quite large
batch sites for this because we wanted
to
uh each batch was consisting of
all of uh of examples of images from
each data set so
large part size was ensuring that each
data set was
sufficiently prevented in each batch
and then for the training steps we used
cosine annealing learning rate decay
and so and and we
and we started with learning rate 0.2
great next question is uh from
the next question is from rashid moin
from microsoft
what is the minimum size of the data set
that you may want to further fine-tune
[Music]
i'm not sure if i'm reading a question
correctly
yeah so i guess general let's describe
what would be your advice on uh given
any organization on earth or any person
trying to solve a vision task
yes how should they determine whether
they should fine-tune this model further
or just take the pre-trained model
yeah so so as you mentioned there are a
couple ways that we can approach this
depending on the resources that we have
we might want if we have
more resources we might want to take our
model and fine-tune it fully
to our new task or if we just if we are
happy with
putting less resource in and uh
just and just want to use model s
we can use it as feature extractor or
just to learn
one linear layer on top of that model
those are the
three most uh most general approaches to
this
and per data set the target data set
size that we might want to use it
uh i don't believe there should be any
problem
with minimal size
obviously if that data set will be very
small
then you might have better better chance
without
training any additional layer because
then
that additional layer would be would
have very little training data
to learn on but you might want to use
the model as a feature extractor only
and then just do zero shot
classification using just the features
if your data is
sufficiently small and when i say
sufficiently small
where some of the tests that we
that we've run uh that we also shared
were on the data set of sizes
as small as couple k a thousand a couple
thousand uh example training examples
uh so this should be sufficient to learn
uh
one linear layer on top but if it's if
we're going
much smaller to hundreds and or even
tens of uh
of images you might want to turn into
zero shots
classification
next question is logistic regression
sufficient or do you need other
classifiers for certain tasks
so logistic regression will work well
in our scenario
classification especially the
larger scale classification
especially a larger scale classification
that
we use for example for for imagenet so
this is we could say sufficient and the
question is
what is the what is the return that you
want to get from this model
uh so i mentioned you can
you can run it in a zero sub
classification that you just use it to
extract the features
then the next kind of cost that you can
pay to train this logistic regression to
improve the performance of that a little
bit
and then every other layer that you will
start adding
will will have vanishing
diminishing results return of your
investment
so i would say generally it is
sufficient
but especially for very specialized
tasks you might
want to add on top more layers to allow
them very special
more specialized knowledge
what is the footprint of this model in
terms of memory size
oh this model that we published is the
regular resin 50
is so the model itself
i believe it takes less than 1 000
sorry 100 megabytes
uh i mean i think that we yeah
if that's the questions about also about
storage of the model
uh of course there is some memory uh
memory
limitations when we run the model in
production
uh but but resin 50 uh
is generally quite quite
compact model and and so you shouldn't
have any troubles with
with running this on unreasonably uh
we run it on the batch sizes like that
on one gpu you'll be able to squeeze in
batch size
uh as loud as i think 1000 if you do
just for propagation
then the next question is is the order
of the tasks that you train
important in the multitask training
setting
and general answers no
tasks are optimized at the same time and
so there is no order to the tasks
[Music]
they are in each each batch is having
examples from each data set
uh yeah so that's the short question
short answer
next question is how do we know how many
layers that we should freeze and how
many layers to be
keep open for further fine tuning that's
actually very good question uh because
this this the answer to the question is
not simple
so for represent our results
uh with other research we we evaluated
it on with one linear layer on top of
our model
and with no further fine tuning right
but depending on your task you might
want to actually uh
freeze some layers unfreeze others and
fine-tune the others
and there's like i would say the whole
separate branch of research that
tries to optimize and fine-tune that
part
so actually the answer for that is not
straightforward we and being
we have we had success with
both freezing that model
but also freezing that model fully but
also when we unfroze some of the layers
like
when you look at the resident 50
architectures you can unfreeze the whole
blocks
so resident 50 consists of four blocks
and we had uh we see uh the result of
model improving if you train for example
only last block or last two blocks of
the resident 50.
so there are absolutely you have to
experiment with this
and there are definitely gains to be to
be gotten this way
next question is from alexander kosmenko
from grid dynamics
it was mentioned that you have data sets
of various sizes how do you weight the
multiple
loss functions in this case
yes so each data set
the way i would say the weight it
contributes to the final loss
is proportional to its size so at the
end of the day if
if some data set is two times larger
than the other
its loss will contribute twice as much
as the smaller data set
this is also very interesting because we
can see this very clearly in
our evaluations and the loss functions
that loss functions for each data set
that
we can see that it's first easy for the
model to start
optimizing those large data sets and
then when it
when this flattens uh you can see that
the loss functions in the model is
looking for those optimizations in
smaller data sets
so this is kind of what how we would
expect model to to behave here
then next question is how did multiple
data set competition work with small
batches
yeah that's exactly uh
the short answer is it didn't very well
so
increasing batch size here was very was
crucial
and using uh like when we when we're
trying with bar sizes like 128
or 2 254
and or even 520 512
we really so much work out and so
in increasing the above size to 100 2000
was crucial to get to get good results
here
then how do you prevent overfitting on
small data sets
so i mentioned that
[Music]
on one side
on one side the model tries to optimize
first large data sets then smaller data
sets
and we can see those log functions going
down for all the data sets
but at the same time those data sets
for each other they they behave like
as regularizers to regularize
the model uh for each asset as well
so if you start overfitting on one data
especially smaller one
it will very soon be visible on large
larger set and the loss on the larger
data set
will keep from that overheating
next question is from stanley moses from
research studio austria fg
based on your experimentation which of
the distance metric has been proven to
work well for
a large scale image retrieval task
uh short answer is causing similarity
uh yeah so we've experimented with with
a few with
uh some more modern and
more classic ones but coffin similarity
works very well for us
a question from carmilla sheikh from
flipkart
what is the metric of evaluation used
for embeddings quality
uh so for this release
and the result that you can see is we
followed the pattern
uh of uh of the clip actually paper from
open ai that was recently released
sorry could you actually repeat the
question
sure thing it is what is the metric of
evaluation you used for the embeddings
quality
yeah yeah so yeah so we train a
linear classifier on top of our metric
[Music]
and then measure the accuracy
on the data sets that we've listed in
the condition
and then the next question is are your
labels multi-class or multi-label in the
training data
so the answer is both
[Music]
some data sets have single label
and some have multi-labels and the multi
for multi-labels we handled
it in a way that let's say that image
has two labels then
we will assign we will assign
this one hot vectors to have values of
0.5 to all the labels that
that are in the label set for for each
image
so in general case if the if the image
has n labels
it will have value 1 divided by n for
each of that
that will be the target for that model
to learn
another question is around the
architecture so
can this training scheme be to can this
training scheme
be used to scheme squeeze more
performance by fine tuning
with other commonly established pure
architectures of resnet
has such attempt being done concurrently
to compare how other architectures fare
in this regard
the general question would be that have
you tried other architectures and
what are some general comments that we
can make about
other architectures than resident 50 if
they have capability of
training a new architecture yes
that's a good question uh so as we said
like in the beginning we mentioned that
uh okay we chose resident 50 here
because we want to showcase that this
method works
and this is actually at least
as good as other methods out there but
but especially
when we when we start to scale to more
tasks
and uh and larger data sets
your uh your return better
with with larger data with larger
architectures so we also
we also experimented with architectures
like
resnex resnext101 or
efficientness and we see that there is
a big there is gain on that task
on that task on that architectures so
i would say that larger
architectures even have a chance to
benefit
more from that approach and than for our
architectures because there's
always the question okay how much can we
actually squeeze out of resonance 50
the answer is maybe maybe a lot maybe a
lot but definitely
definitely larger architectures are
still under
fitting to to their top to lots of the
vision tasks that they've been given
so they have the capability of very well
generalized into multiple tasks within
the same architecture
next question is the figure that you had
shown for multitask learning has common
feature layer for all tasks
how did you handle coarse and
fine-grained discrimination variations
across the tasks
yes that's a very good question
so naturally
so some of the datasets that we use are
more fine grained
and some are more cold grain coarse
grained
so i wouldn't say so that the
normally how you would approach a fine
grade class
uh find great recognition is that you
would do some metric learning some
contrastive loss
so we didn't do it here so we kind of uh
treat we treat each task as a
classification task
and we saw uh how
what kind of uh can you learn
features that will model both fine grain
and coarse grained
those tasks i wouldn't
say we any of our methods that we use
was specifically designed for
fine-grained
tasks but as it turns out
uh like the the architecture of the
architecture that we use
and it allowed us to to generalize well
into
both of those type of tasks
next question how do i interpret the
output array of the model
i guess you could give a intuitive uh
interpretation of
what is being represented in the vectors
yes so i would say it's tough to
interpret the output uh just like by
looking at it
and and uh for definitely for for
humans this will be this will not be
possible
to say anything about the the image so
the output is just a 2040 embedding that
was
that was performing well on the
classification
of one linear layer so the only
thing we as human can can derive from
looking at the output is the similarity
between
uh two images we can compare the cosine
similarity between two vectors to
measure the similarity between images
but i wouldn't go anywhere else with the
interpretation of
that array next question
have you attached have you attempted to
distill the model
or any other compressions
uh i'm
i'm assuming that which what is meant
by this question is that if we take
our model and perform distillation to
the other model
uh so the answer would be no
we didn't do the distillation of that
model because usually the way the
distillation is that you would take
much larger model and then distill into
into this one
so while this is a valid approach that
that also could could work well in this
case
uh we that
that would definitely put in doubt the
kind of integrity of our
our result it was that resonance 50
actually trained on its own or was it
distilled from from larger model
so to keep it pure we didn't do
distillation for that experimentation
here
but still distillation is definitely
is something that we will use internally
to obtain as strong models as possible
another question from stanley moses from
research studio austria fg
stan stanley has used feature vectors
before and had hard time
debugging it do you have any advice on
how
stanley could improve accuracy
uh sure i mean i would have to have more
details about
what which results
actually didn't uh performance expected
will definitely
publish the notebooks that you will be
able to
replicate the scores that we published
[Music]
yeah i think in general in general
let alone this model but any vision
model that would
represent images as embeddings and using
that in part of
larger computer vision systems how would
you
even imagine somebody runs the system
and gets low accuracy
how would you advise them to further
debug
find out where it's going wrong and then
improve the system
yeah i think uh there especially our
experimentation we noticed that
really small tweaks can matter a lot in
terms of accuracy so we need to take
care of things like proper image
normalization make sure that
the format of the image is the same as
expected by the model because our model
expects expects images in bgr format as
opposed to rgb
so i think that first we need to make
sure that all those little details
are are correct and
i hope that that the notebooks that
we'll publish will help with this
yeah i want to pause for one minute and
thank everybody for
asking great questions i think we'll be
taking about two more questions
and then uh if you have pressing
questions please keep them coming
unless we see any very important
questions we'll end with the next two
questions
the next one is from jezia zakharov from
qatar university
you've seen great results by training on
many different data sets what do you
expect
uh will happen to accuracy if you train
on even more data sets
you already reached 92 percent do you
expect it to go even further will there
be diminishing returns
yeah so i think it's the question
of how good our uh approach will be
versus the the specialized approach like
uh
the the approach that will train on just
one data right
so if we just run on on image set let's
say then then we know that we can we can
uh get get higher results as you can
see from the python model train just on
image network has higher image and
results than ours
now the question is how much of the
score we can we can save
we can save by adding more more data
sets
and so definitely for more general
uh so for more general data sets
there will be some loss once we start
adding more data sets
so we're looking for this kind of sweet
spot
of the data sets that we're still
generating well
but but at the same uh keeping the
performance but at the same time
offering us uh good performance across
many times
but i would say that for more
surprisingly for uh
more fine grain and specialized tasks
adding some other uh adding some other
tasks might even have
positive uh positive influence on those
tasks because as i mentioned those
larger tasks
often you can treat them as a
regularization
method to your model and they are
very well preventing overfitting on them
so
definitely while you'll be increasing
number of data sets
your the the scores will start to go
down
but it has to be it has to be considered
case by case
and then the next question is the last
question so zigman you answer lots of
great questions hopefully now you can
drink water and take a break
next question is from faith wambua who
is a student in kenya
what approach would you recommend to
deep blur images before classification
by resonant 50.
i think we can take this question a
little more general and talk about
what are pre-processing techniques that
you would use to
the image itself before fitting into
microsoft vision model
yeah i see your
[Music]
so we used
for training standard image processing
which did not include the blurring
images
images used for our training are usually
already
quite high quality
so i wouldn't say they needed the
blurring
and when i say thunder pre-processing i
mean
like resizing cropping and flipping the
uh flipping them vertically
but there definitely is
value in curating the the dataset that
you use for
for training and
but i would say it doesn't uh
you will have much more uh much more
success
by trying to remove the outliers for
each
class
for each each class of the image look
for outliers and
removing them from the data set then
looking at the images themselves and
trying to declare them
and with that last question we'll now
close the live q a
thanks to all the attendees for coming
to our webinar and once again as
reminders for how you can review and
learn more
you can visit aka dot ms slash micro
subvision model to return to our
announcements
aka dot ms slash microsoft vision to
return to the model itself which which
is a python package with our
example usage code that you saw today
and then aka that ms slash being
multimedia jobs if you want to join our
team
and work on world leading computer
vision models
such as this one or fine grain
recognition models that are downstream
object detection so on
so with that thanks to everyone for uh
coming and hope to see you in our next
announcements
thank you very much